une haute silhouette habillé de métal
sur le beffroi un échafaudage en
encorbellement de 43 mètres de haut
spectaculaire est nécessaire la
restauration du bâtiment était devenue
une priorité qui a des poutres qui sont
très très abîmée y en a même qui se sont
désolidarisés et il ya des gros travaux
à faire il ya toute la couverture à
refaire également et ce bâtiment était
menacé de s'effondrer par parking la
hauteur créer une contrainte et l'état
du bâtiment surtout à l'arrière crée
aussi une autre contrainte qui
permettait pas un appui sur la nef
particulier sur la partie arrière pas de
rénovation intégrale mais un
remplacement cibler des éléments abîmé
un chantier bien spécifiques de grande
hauteur compliquée par l'environnement
urbain et piétonniers et la ville s'est
reconstruite en fait autour de ce
bâtiment et a complètement enclavé
l'immeuble on va dire avec des ruelles
très étroites et même des façades non
accessibles donc la principale
difficulté c'est vraiment gérer l'accès
au chantier
le projet coûtera près d'un million
trois cent mille euros pris en charge en
majorité par la ville un investissement
justifiée par l'intérêt patrimonial de
l'ensemble architectural c'est quand
même un bâtiment qui date de la fin du
14e siècle
le beffroi y est heures ayant été
rajoutés au xvème siècle
si vous voulez ici c'était la
corporation des bouchers qui occupaient
les locaux et chaussées est au dessus il
y avait le bailliage c'est à dire
toute la justice comtal donc c'est un
bâtiment extrêmement important les
intempéries du début d'année ont quelque
peu ralenti le démarrage des travaux
si les délais sont respectés le chantier
est censé durer 22 mois